welcome back to the machine learning
Street talk YouTube channel with me Tim
scarf my two compadres Yannick Kilcher
Lightspeed Kilcher and Connor shorten so
today we have an incredibly special
guest syak pool and syak lives in
Kolkata and he's really well-known in
the deep learning community I mean I've
known about psychic for ages now because
of some of the articles that he's
written he's recognized by Intel as
being an Intel software innovator and
they recognized him as one of their top
innovators in 2019 he's also a Google
developer expert at GD II in machine
learning and he's currently working as a
deep learning associate at PI image
search and he's kind of applying deep
learning for solving real world problems
in computer vision and bringing these
solutions to edge devices like Raspberry
Pi in Nvidia Jetson nano and that sort
of thing so he does a lot of community
outreach now I know psychic does a lot
of stuff in the weights and biases slack
he's also all over social channels he's
all over Twitter is on the AI DL he's on
LinkedIn
he's absolutely everywhere he's got a
website he's written loads of articles
and possibly best of all he's written a
really cool book on deep learning called
Python deep learning for the web which
he co-authored and why don't I share my
screen to show you some of this goodness
because it's just too much good stuff
for us just to talk about hypothetically
you know what we need to do is to share
the screen and spread the love so so X
website is that on syak dev and as you
can see here he's got loads and loads of
cool information he collects together
some of his articles his articles are
actually published on towards data
science now he wrote a really good one
that I read a few weeks ago on pruning
and neural networks
and as you can see from science style
it's very practical it's very useful and
there's lots of code examples in this
case using carers so I'd thoroughly
recommend you check this out he's also
written articles on things like
reproducibility and machine learning
engineering and so I axe book is here so
it's by Packt publishing and it's called
hands-on Python deep learning for the
web so make sure you will go and check
that book out and otherwise just
based on what I've seen SIA Keys got
loads of interest in this field so for
example machine learning
interpretability reproducibility and ml
engineering pruning unsupervised
contrasted learning full-stack data
science writing these technical articles
and also giving talks that developer
meetups and so on so sorry okay so
pleasure to have you on the show
thank you so much for joining us it's
probably my pleasure because I've been
always motivated by you folks seeing all
of your educational content and so on it
has its continues to you know motivate
me and pursue the things that I love so
yeah thanks for having me and it's my
pleasure as well oh that's fantastic
well why don't you tell us about your
journey into machine learning yeah sure
so I'm not really frankly speaking I
passed out in 2017 my aunt passed out
from my undergraduate so I got hooked to
machine learning when I discovered this
undergrad force called pattern
recognition and machine learning and so
incidentally it's also a book by
Christopher Bishop so and that's also
one of the book that that was
recommended during our course so that
was an elective though so I fortunately
soup that electives pattern recognition
and machine learning so once I started
you know reading it studying intense
stuff I signed up got hooks and so yeah
that that's what got me started into the
field so to speak and then I sort of you
know continued from there I haven't been
a web developer or a developer guys in
my period at whatever point in time I
have always been interested in forcing
machine learning and deep learning
specifically I am interested in general
representation learning a lot so yeah
that's that's kind of how my journey got
started and yes so far it's been amazing
with all the ups and downs perhaps if I
were to tell how did I go how did I get
started probably that university under
that cord got me started into purchasing
this piece well that's amazing you're a
huge inspiration because so many people
want to make their mark in machine
learning and one
make a successful career in machine
learning and you seem to be
demonstrating a lot of very positive
attributes that have worked for you
I'm not sure whether you could unpack
that but things like being a teacher
writing high quality content networking
successfully just being really really
good at distilling down information I
mean if you could kind of formalize some
of those things that have helped you the
most what would what would you say it
was yep probably one of these advices
that I get a lot from all the people
that I follow all the people like you
that I follow is probably the best way
to you know understand machine learning
is to teach it and it's kind of applied
to learning in general so to speak so
whenever I was you know getting started
when I was getting started in the field
I used to you know take notes and you
not discuss all the concepts with my
fellow peers and I used to you know take
pseudo classes for them to make you know
to you know make some content really
easy to understand and stuff like that
so write writing and teaching it's
something that you know phrase honest
with me a lot and I find it's really
useful to you know to be able to convey
a very complex information in simpler
manners and discuss this because this
means content with my peers with
like-minded people I like you so if I
were to formalize certain things that
have really helped me in pursuing this
field in the way I have always wanted to
is first is learn by teaching stuff by
discussing stuff with other people and
always try to you know get the
motivation right in front of your heads
I mean yeah you could be studying you
know residual networks at any given
point in time but always you know
motivates that learning as to as to the
as to what motivated the development of
residual learning you could be learning
about people learning at any given point
in thing but it's probably what to know
why residual networks are important to
study in the forces right I mean
overcoming the representational
bottlenecks and stuff that's one of the
primary reasons for developing an
architecture like this one is module in
force and stuff so yeah I try to always
you know motivate my learning by
things like that try to reason with
things let their development and stuff
so two things if I were to summarizes
learn by you know discussing and
teaching and also second point would be
to you know try to being able to you
know reason with the stuff that later
development some cares nobody thoughts
are on you write a lot of articles where
you have code examples and then staying
on top of the research how do you blend
between implementing practical things
that are you know a bit more low-hanging
fruit and easier to actually build and
then staying up with the most
cutting-edge paper that comes out and
how do you kind of balance that
information diet of these two kind of
activities you can pursue yeah I think I
have I have a very very well how do
anything I mean I have a very narrow
approach towards I won't read you know
all of the papers that are coming out I
generally start by going through going
through the abstract first and if that
piques my interest
I generally I generally see one of your
videos either it has to be either from
you it has to be or from Jana called
from Tim and then you know I try to
detail my understanding after going
through the papers isolative Lee and
that's what if and after after doing the
titled its process if I feel the need to
implement the things I mean if I get
excited after reading the papers in that
I traded process if I feel the need to
implement it myself I go ahead and spin
up a collab notebook and try to come up
with a minimal implementation yeah yeah
that's what that that's what always has
been my UPS no chance
regarding the you know regarding
balancing between information diagrams
stuff
I basically love this field I love by
swinging it so that's what has always
motivated me to pursue it more and more
and I always try to you know incorporate
or rather mary applied research into
engineering best practices let's say I
would try to motivate motivate and
implementation with regards to its needs
let's say I am dealing with the problem
where I do not have a lot of labeled
data sets so naturally I would try
to look for a technique that utilizes a
lot of unlabeled data and try to learn
useful representations so yeah seam
sealer
might be a pretty natural natural
architecture natural methodology to go
for here so that's how I you know try to
blend the applied research into some
engineering problems or rather you know
industrial industry specific things so
yeah that's how I try to you know blend
the information that in between could
you take me a little through more or
your experience it's working with the
collab notebooks because I had tried it
out maybe three months ago and it was
kind of like you'd be in a queue waiting
for it so I you know I haven't really
been too interested in it but can you
tell me how this is like what your
experience has been using it and kind of
some of the pitfalls of it and is it is
it what's something you see yourself
using for the next say two to three
years definitely for the next next year
I'd be using a collab but I don't know I
don't know if I if Koehler actually
makes you you know wait to be able to
you know get a jeep you enable instance
probably a il kernel has been doing that
that's using kind of things but I've
been using polar for the past two years
now I haven't really faced any such
issues but they are there the problem of
you know GPU instances and so on
probably that because it's all free so
at any given point in time let's say
well slab gave you a creative instance
and after one after an hour when you
would do units try to spin up the same
column notebook you might not get the
same HTTP it might get idle enhancer yes
it will stay to stay to KC so that's
something to care about but so far my
experience with fuller has been super
productive because you know to be able
to come up with faster and improved and
enhance data input pipelines what I
often do is I try putting everything in
a Google Cloud Storage bucket so that
you know CPU and stuff like that can
interact with it in an easier manner so
it's also a bit it's also a good
practice to keep all of your data in a
GCS budget specifically if you are using
Google Cloud
stuff like that and koala also offers
you free if you photon stuff so I
generally prefer to keep all of my data
in a JC sealed socket and I find it you
know faster that's it the model training
often gets faster for that but they are
for minimal experimentations and stuff
like that ideally spin apocalypse collab
know who can use whatever GPU is
allocated see me so yeah long story cut
short here there it would be collab
notebook has been super productive in
all of all of the stuff that I do
so just to stay on quickly the
networking bottleneck where you're
getting your data and from the Google
cloud bucket and then passing it to
collab so is the networking with the
collab and and the cloud bucket is that
a big bottleneck or is it you know not
such a problem yes it generally depends
on the kind of data that you are dealing
with so far most of the day does it's
like images and stuff like that what I
normally do is I create I'll mostly
voltage and current errors and the
native data structure that ends up on
Terra's operated its Interflora codes so
for most of the day that it's primarily
it's not really a big deal to convert
the entire dataset into shards of items
of no defaults so I won't really fall
that to be important next so far in my
journey that hasn't been important link
really but yeah the process can get very
overwhelming as you scale up your
datasets and stuff so yeah you'd need to
find some kind of trade of this with
regards to you know the technical dates
the usability and the simplicity of the
entire pipeline that you are English and
in that pipeline if I were to draw
simplicity trade offs and stuff like
that I would go for you know creating
here GF records and have them placed
over a DPS bucket and then I will I will
delete them in my development
environment so tensorflow records is
also is the tf2 diet data a different
thing and like so it's tensorflow
records your preferred way to work with
the data and is that are there other
ways of doing it like I remember when I
first got familiar with tensor flow
records I don't use it now I you know
use this TF the data object and I think
I passed in like an umpire right is that
the fastest way you're doing it
like how is working with the tensorflow
records object yeah so at its core
Center flow records are nothing but
frozen waffles it's a very lightweight
file structure and it's very efficient
to store data in general on this you've
got details specifically a set of API
that can unify all of this you know
different formats together so it's
absolutely possible to directly load any
kind of data that's supported by give
the data from from a GCS buckets and
yeah as you mentioned correctly which
number is also to give dot data would
work and there the specific CF s--
record data fix that's provided by 30 of
the data to the Fabian's that allows you
to you know put it on so record as
smoothly as possible it out for its
functionalities like mapping
interleaving prefetching and stuff like
that I've had some experience doing you
know tends to flow Jas and things like
this and in general I was wondering what
your opinion was on machine learning you
know these kind of end devices because I
mean we I guess there is one thing where
you say you want we want to deploy a
model on end devices right and that they
run on these devices but is there do you
see any any application of doing actual
learning on these end devices because it
seems like it's always just way faster
to ship something to a GPU in like a
central place even if even if you had
like five thousand raspberry PI's they
would probably not be as fast as my
single gaming GPU right so I was
wondering if you if you had an
experience what are your experience with
kind of these edge devices and do you
see that deployment is hard I see that
or where do you see that the kind of is
there an application where we could
learn there yeah so there are a couple
of pointers I mean thanks for the great
question for me so on device learning
specifically is absolutely possible
specifically nowadays Google launched
this coral set of you know GPU
escalators and stuff like that which
make on device training possible to some
extent
specifically with techniques like weight
imprinting and stuff like that so yeah
on device training is possible but only
to a certain extent not like you're
trained a full-fledged full-blown image
classification systems on tiny devices
like this but yeah to some extent on
device training is possible and
regarding you know coming - it's coming
- your question on deep floppy flowing
this thing on tiny devices such as wheel
by and so on so I would still argue that
there are quite a lot of places on our
odds well you know network bandwidth
Hardware bandwidth are still kind of
problems there are still bottlenecks to
that and moreover moreover there can be
you know privacy issues close there
might be need for clothes close-knit
interactions and stuff like that so I
kind of have a very broader view on the
on the index topic of deployment of this
models on devices such as - vilify and
so on I kind of see it as a way to
optimize my model and anyway if you are
deploying your heavy wet ones you would
want to ideally optimize them so as to
you know reduce your network bandwidth
and at the same time the space because
if you kind of optimize your models
specifically if you point out your model
without you know affecting your models
accuracy in the forces and you would
ideally be saving a lot of space right
because reducing your model size from a
GB 200 MB would you know give you not
only size improvement but it might be
also the case that it's still producing
the same performance so it also saves
the architectural cost in the first
place right
so naturally you'd you would want to
approach this like hips what would be
the cost to host a GB of model and
versus what would be the cost towards
100 MB model so yeah that way so I kind
of see it as a mirror model optimization
problem and yes so far my experience
with on device machine learning has been
good so I am interested in purchasing
this borders which you know fix with all
the techniques
they're coming in with pruning
quantisation knowledge disposition and
so on okay that's I mean that's yes
thanks
of course there yeah especially again
it's related to privacy is relevant to
us all but as you say there are its
parts of the world that are not very
well connected still and I get you
living in Kolkata probably you are faced
much more with with that around you then
then we are do you know of any if you
have any local experience it's like
where you can say oh look here is
something special that machine learning
is doing for my for my communities here
that that we might not be aware of I'm
not sure if you are not aware of this
but yeah India is primarily an
agricultural country so there are a lot
of farmers here in our country and I
come from a rural area I still do not
live in a very urban place where you
know I live in an area where carrying a
guitar in your back it fills you know is
still a thing I would say food uncoated
Philips things carrying a guitar on your
back so yeah I have seen you know the
entire agricultural industry getting
very very much affected in a positive
way with regard to machine learning will
it seems like slán disease
classification and so on planned landing
insect localization and so on so far it
has been able to you know enhance the
lives of power forward to a great extent
and there's something called M krishi
this is this is a far more friendly
application well they use machine level
fightable
so yeah I would say that these these
applications of machine learning and
extremely regional and local to the kind
of demography I am talking about so yes
that's it that's pretty amazing
I mean I've mean that the potential
there our guest is just it's just really
large to to make big impacts in people's
lives I guess we're almost feels feels
kind of dumb we are like trying to
distinguish cats from dogs and upsample
the doom guy that there are there are
more important problems to be solved so
with generally maybe you can you can
speak I don't know how
you can speak to that but the academic
landscape in in India how do you see
that is it do you think it's a problem
that a lot of people you know at least
in my university we do have every we do
have a large number of students from
from India and I think also US
universities have a large number of
applicants and students from India do
you see it how do you how does that look
from your perspective or people like
wanting to go away for good or the
people going and trying to bring the
knowledge back is there how many people
are there they're trying to stay in the
country I'm just wondering about kind of
how how the your experiences of the ml
community or the technical community in
general yeah sure so I think there's a
good trade-off in between the two so
there are there that there is a set of
people that are you know that are trying
to come back and share their knowledge
with the community but also there is a
set of people that are trying to you
know that are trying to have their
education and stuff from the foreign
country so there is a very well balanced
trade-off here but the general academic
scenario here in India is more towards
you know numeric system girl stuff the
more drills that you achieve the better
student you might be that the primarily
thought of academic systems in India so
which is a bummer I would say I would
admit that this is a pretty grave bummer
and many universities here they do they
do not do not encourage forcing the
pages in the way you folks would as you
I mean pursuing a PhD is kind of a like
same thing where you would like to
devote yourself to finding something
that's truly noble and truly bring
something in the field of your interest
but in some universities here in India
they just do it for the sake of research
I mean they would you know pursue
research like doing incorporating
genetic algorithm for object detection
they would not consider you know that
kind of impact
they would not consider you know doing
any objection
studies or you know just going through
the kind of work that has been done in
the year of in the entire area of
dictation so that Darrell that's also a
grave bummer
that I hope that I would mention but at
the same time there are certain
universities like IIT Madras IIT Kanpur
IIT Bombay where people are doing quite
cutting-edge research and one of the
universities that I I would like to
specifically mention its triple IT
Hyderabad where there are a number of
folks doing great work in the area of
computer vision in general so yeah
that's the kind of opinion and view that
I have for academic landscapes here in
India cool I mean I'm looking looking
forward to other parts of the world also
becoming kind of powerhouses of of new
innovation and I I think that's you know
on the horizon and yeah I welcome that I
went to Hyderabad when I worked at
Microsoft and it's an absolutely
fascinating place it's just bustling
with activity and it's definitely going
to be one of the future super centers of
technology and I was looking through
some of your interests and you know just
a signpost some of the things that I
think we should talk about there's
machine learning interpretability you
wrote an article on reproducibility you
just wrote an article on pruning I'm not
sure if you watched our episode last
week but we had Robert land John and
he's also written an article on pruning
and it's such an amazing time to be
alive I mean we had Frank Allen here a
couple of months ago and you know I'm
just so excited about the pruning
literature it's just it's taken off and
it's gone in a really interesting
direction I think I CML is this week if
I'm not mistaken and I think Jonathan is
presenting his linear mode connectivity
paper yeah and the other thing that we
prepared to talk about today was
unsupervised contrasted learning for 4ml
so out of those topics which one would
you like to double click on to coin some
jargon first yeah I think representation
learning is something that fascinates me
a lot so yeah let's talk about
unsupervised contracts in learning
engines okay
amazing well this is one of those things
where I would like you to frame it up so
because we've done a few
about some of the approaches to you know
contrasted unsupervised representation
learning how do you see it from your
perspective
yeah I think the you know the very
philosophy of incorporating data
augmentation into the picture and doing
it on a large corpus of you know
unlabeled data set and having the
contrast is lost in the picture gives us
a pretty nice and solid framework to be
able to be able to you know learn
general visual representation visual
representations and being able to you
know fine-tune them to the downstream
car so yeah if I were to summarize you
recipe here that really make them work
in the way they should be
first and foremost would be larger batch
sizes with large optimizer second would
be learning rate schedule with cosine
digits how it would be stronger data
augmentation policies and you cannot
afford to miss horizontal flips and
colored details and so on and your
originated 54 the win-win for yes I mean
it's not only simplistic but also it's
kind of intuitive to think about it as
to why it can you know give us visual
representations that are not only
effective for a single touch but also
effective for a number of different
tasks as well I mean the this general
framework allows us to you know
generalize well to the other downstream
tasks even in the presence of very less
label data this this particular fact is
quite fascinating to me oh yeah that's
one of the most practical advices I've
ever heard that's awesome it's like hey
okay you need to do this this learning
rate these three augmentations boom I
[Laughter]
know Connor is chomping at the bit to
talk about data augmentations because
this is his favorite subject that just
before I let Conte you know grab you at
both hands do you have any opinions on
data augmentations in general because we
were discussing this the other week and
what's interesting is that computer
vision models they don't learn they
don't learn the kind of features that
humans learn they learn these weird high
frequency patterns
and similarly the kind of data
augmentations that seem to work well
they're not really the kind of
augmentations that you know that a human
orientated that they're quite peculiar
in a way so yeah how do you kind of
rationalize that yeah I think I think
this is one of those areas where you
would still need to do a lot of research
to be able to you know appreciate the
understanding so this is exactly what I
was going to tell in one of the for that
discussion and this very session so it's
I think it's about to be well
really well understood as to why
stronger data-orientation policies
actually helps the the contrast of
learning tasks in the journal although
we see some energy in the skin clear and
the faint here v2 paper but I think it's
yet to be really well under understood
as to why this peculiar data
augmentation operations really works
well I mean operations like color
doodling colored its distortions and so
on III know I don't find them you know
very consistent with the kind of human
concepts that we would build to
understand a particular image so yes
that's that would be my opinion I mean
I'm actually looking forward to seeing
research that would you know help us
understand this thing really really well
I mean not just from empirical point of
view but also somewhat theoretical point
of view as to why the documentation I
mean very specifically this mierda data
augmentations really helps the contacts
in learning tasking well yeah I think
with the contrastive learning task it's
pretty clear that you know we're forming
the self supervised learning tasks by
augmenting in and getting a positive
sample but relating it back to this idea
of is data augmentation how we learn is
something I've been thinking about it I
mean it would be a hard thing to probe
for right like how would you test that
but I think it could be possible that
there's some kind of like subconscious
process that has some form of like
augmenting the data and then just
skipping another view at it could just
be like a noise injection or maybe like
maybe you learn these transformations in
your head and it's like
I think like rotation and flipping and
shifting and all that it's a really good
prior that we put into this because we
know these kinds of invariances but
maybe things like differentiable data
augmentation maybe we can learn new data
augmentations that are more powerful and
whether it's stronger necessarily is it
stronger is like an odd term a bit right
it's like stronger by stronger do you
mean like you've transformed it more
like the distance of the pixels is more
so or is it like semantically morphing
the image which could be interesting too
but I I impression actually with the
contrast of self supervised learning is
that this self training thing is kind of
the hot ticket that this is the you know
the data augmentation I haven't seen
anything that's like really new yet
recently but the self training idea oh
sorry yeah it's an interesting
hypothesis that human beings might do
some kind of data augmentation and I
immediately thought of dreaming when we
dream our brain runs these simulations
and we've been discussing that what
makes system to is having imagination
and planning and being able to
combinatorially combine known concepts
into this huge space of possible
situations that might happen so maybe
it's not such a crazy idea after all
yeah I've come to think of it I've come
to think of dreaming as like kind of
being in like a sensory deprivation tank
where it's like your internal model just
keeps doing its thing despite turning
off the input sensors and I think it
might be different from an idea of like
a subconscious data augmentation where
you're like processing all this data
maybe and I think those I think dreaming
and data augmentation in our brains
could be separate things but the other
thing is there's there's data synthesis
and there's data for augmentation do you
think humans are capable of data
synthesis and what would that mean yeah
that's a really interesting thing to
think about it's this so we talked about
like a differentiable data augmentation
where we would might like learn the
parameters of a rotation like a rotation
is an F of that
transforming the exit rotation but maybe
we could like learn the parameters of
some rotation or maybe we can have a
generative model and that might be like
because we have our internal model that
sends out how we've interpreted the data
so maybe the the generative model is
what does it like when you look at image
GPT and they cut off the bottom half of
the image and then they auto
aggressively fill it in that could be a
really interesting data augmentation and
it's like amazing to me that began this
is a paper titled classification
accuracies score for evaluating
generative models where you train the
classifier on the generated data and
they try this with big and vector
quantized variational auto encoder and I
think they use one of these flow based
models too although I don't know much
about how that works but it still
doesn't work which is pretty interesting
you know that training on the gand data
or just adding it to the data set
doesn't already work but I think that
data augmentation paired with generative
models I think that's going to be on the
frontier that I mean do you have any
thoughts on why that doesn't work Conor
is laying the case for being able to
generate data or augment our knowledge
about something by modifying knowledge
we already have and that I think the
philosophical question is can we learn
the unknown unknowns by synthesizing or
modifying things that we already have
and my intuition on that is the answer
is no but I I I would love to be
convinced otherwise well what about this
in in Tsim clear in that framework what
if instead of the positive sample being
the rotated version of the same image
it's like the five nearest neighbors in
the gann Laden space or something like
that like if that's how we're
constructing our positive and negative
samples has something to do with the
Leighton space of a generative model I
mean it's generative models should have
like a data augmentation type of
transformation in them right like as you
walk along the Leighton space it's some
kind of transformation
that's different from rotation and all
it's different from something we could
design and and philosophically that
there's an interplay between priors and
experience so priors are the hardware
experiences kind of like the software if
you like before we used to handcraft
everything we used to explicitly tell
the Machine what to do and now with
machine learning where we are learning
what to do and creating a data
synthesizer is kind of like you're
writing some code to generate data so
maybe you could argue that's just the
same as writing code but it's it's
transforming it's turning into
experience in practice and data
augmentations seem to be somewhere in
the middle where you start with some
known data that you are encoding some
it's not an inductive prior it's
something in the middle you're encoding
some kind of knowledge to transform that
data into more data I can think we've
touched on this before it's where we
used to engineer features right and now
we're just engineering augmentations I
mean have we have really really comfort
is you know like we're just we're just
in hand engineering these augmentations
so maybe sorry you have a you have
comment on so my big question with
respect to these augmentations is I
don't like them they're hand engineer
they're like a bunch of humans sit down
and they're like all I think I can flip
this image like it's completely
arbitrary the color do you do you see a
future like where we do representation
learning without these handcrafted
augmentations because it just seems so
arbitrary and and and it seems to work
for images and but do you see any way
out of out of this or because the trend
right now if I understand it correct and
correct me if I'm wrong is that we need
more augmentations correct is there a
way out of this I mean the kind of
papers that we have recently
specifically fume clear and sing clear
v2 I don't think data orientation is
gonna leave us anytime soon the very
idea of you know
six data augmentation policies like in
Sinclair papers they use the color
chittering and color distortion in a
very stochastic way while keeping the
augmentation policies like horizontal
slipping random random crops and
subjects so some amount of stochasticity
is there so to that end I think
stochastic the documentation policies
like the ones introduced in seem clear
would say at least in the visual
representation learning test but I would
also love to see simpler determination
policies like card makes are of mixers
something like mix up how that can you
know give us some improvements in this
unsupervised visual representation
learning test because if you take a look
at this all these papers on supervised
learning tests they do not do no
experiment with you know mix up or OGG
mix are Cognex probably because the
there is some kind of dependency on the
labels in the first place but I would
love to see you know simpler or medicine
techniques like the ones that I just
mentioned being used in unsupervised
visual representation learning fast in
general can I explore that just quickly
Jannik when you were saying you don't
like data augmentations if there if
there is a continuum between experience
and priors are you saying you would
prefer that we had more priors rather
than more experience no I
I think these augmentations they are the
priors right we we as humans basically
say you model you should not pay
attention to the exact location of
things in a picture that's what we do
with random cropping right what we're
saying
you model you should my mind is coming
back to the Yan laocoon defenestration
and he pointed out the data set bias
thing and of course in the the world he
was illustrating this I don't think he
was talking about data augmentations
he was saying that a convolutional
neural network doesn't really have
racial bias because it's just doing what
it does
and data augmentation seemed to be
halfway between experienced and priors
so your you're encoding some knowledge
definitely data augmentations you could
argue would have some kind of bias which
is undesirable but the alternative would
be if you went more towards creating
more inductive priors
maybe we can improve on the CN n I mean
lots of researchers have created
versions of the C and then that work on
different manifolds and can learn
different types of symmetries and
there's almost no limits what we can do
there and the more knowledge we encode
into our inductive priors the less data
we need the better the sample efficiency
so are you saying that we should be
focusing on the architecture more no I I
want I want an unsupervised
representation learning and without
manually having to specify my date
should be invariant and I know that's a
dream and I also don't want it to work
it without labels this it's just you
know pie in the sky utopia but maybe
here's a question maybe desire q you
having let read lots of papers and stuff
about this notice what's the
relationship between these augmentations
and more data like is is there is there
could we always achieve the same let's
say performance that we achieved through
augmentation by simply having more data
or is this really qualitatively
different like it's the model really
getting better in a different way by
augmenting that we couldn't achieve by
simply collecting you know maybe maybe
needs a hundred times more data but is
there is there a difference doing this
basically only because because we don't
have enough data or is there some some
real difference yeah so the latest work
on filtering rethinking retraining and
filtering where they kind of where the
other kind of showed that how you know
how the architectures can how certain
training paradigms in fact like
supervised learning and still supervised
learning specifically in free training
can get hurt with stronger strong
data augmentation qualities and stuff so
what I would do is I would take the
general representations
general visual representations as
learned by self training and I would try
to you know visualize the intermediate
feature maps as to how you know how
incorporating self training with strong
stronger data augmentation policies
actually helps them to achieve better
performance and stuff and the authors
also showed that not only strong it's
not only shine with stronger data
augmentation policies but also when you
kind of add more data to it then also
self training continues to improve the
performance while supervised free
training and self supervised free
training get hurt so this is something
that I would personally want to do that
is to you know really get into the in
front of models that that train building
self training and you know visualize the
intermediate exhibitions and so on to be
able to infer or you know come up with
any hypothesis yeah yeah it sort of
shows that it sort of shows that you
know there is there's something to this
that even with machine learners while
the streams if we have all the data in
the world that it's there's still
something extra right and I find that
interesting yeah we wanted to talk about
this fixed match framework because this
is like this consistency regularization
with data augmentation it's like the
data augmentation is the workhorse like
how would how would you like scale up
the size of your data set to make this
not help anymore
if that's a good question because I see
this consistency regularization between
these predictions and how like how else
would you get two different views of the
same image and enforce this kind of you
know this is this is obviously a strong
prior I think but how else would you do
this you mean yeah at being contrary I'm
not saying
I'm not saying more data with more data
you could run the same objective what
I'm what basically my my question is is
the the gains that we're making with
these augmentations are those the same
mittenz that would simply happen if we
had more data if we pipe more data into
our you know classifier or are these
completely different and I guess what's
I just said makes a strong point to the
program and that they are actually DIF
there's something extra that we learn I
lift reading in these augmentations and
that's you know I find that pretty the
like that's that's awesome that's
something on like kind of points to
something new and something we do not
know about these models yet yeah yes so
black and white because the intuition is
when we create data augmentations we
effectively increase the size of our
data set so it's almost as if we had a
larger if we could sample from the
distribution of our data set and we
could sample more it's as if we had more
but as you say it's not quite as simple
as that because what we've actually done
is we've we've augmented images that we
already have but we've designed
imitations that kind of perturb or
mutate the image in a way that is
semantically equivalent so what we're
doing is we're helping the algorithm
still learn the difference between the
semantic information and the non
semantic information but you could
reasonably argue that it's not going to
be diversity sampled both the the
semantic information and the not
semantically information as compared to
if we didn't a shion's and we just had a
bigger data set so the exact extent to
which it's not as good as just having a
bigger data set is a fascinating
question yeah exactly so to this end I
think two things that I would love to
see work I will give coming up with
works is how how could we you know
incorporate things like joint training
to parallely learn at us and at the same
time we learn some differential data
augmentation policies with the with
with the kind of paradigm of joint
training it's supposed in the latest
sales training people and also what I
would like to see is how a kind of
ablation study as to how different data
augmentation policies actually affect a
particular task at hand is its task
independent or how does it really you
know vary from such tasks and what kind
of complementation quality is really you
know ring out with respect to any given
task was there something like that in
the sims TLR taper I seem to remember
they did quite a good ablation over the
different augmentations but that was
only for one task though presumably yeah
so yeah so that question that I would
like to its Norris is is the kind of
determination qualities that we see
these days are they are tasks
independent specifically in the domain
of visual representation learning so how
would that scale out and also how would
that scale out as we would scale the
database we see some kind of synergy in
the free thinking free training and
self-training paper but I would love to
see more work on that I think an
interesting philosophical discussion
there is are the augmentations coupled
to the the inductive prior the
architecture so are they related to the
fact that we are using at CNN or are
they related to the the way that cameras
work and the way that we you know have
take images in any environment or are
they related to the actual semantic
information you know that whether it's a
dog or whether it's a drilling head or
something or is it some combination of
the above I paint funny if it's like you
need to you need to always use a random
crop when it's a dog but you can't
always horizontally flip the cats and
it's best I'm going to have to leave it
it was it was like a real it was a real
pleasure to meet you am very very sorry
to jump in for a colleague right here so
oh my god cheers Jenni lazy so finishing
that that thought really quickly this is
kind of where we were at the beginning
by saying that these data augmentations
they don't seem to be related to the
actual physical object in space and they
don't seem to be related to the way that
we recognize objects they seem to be
related to the way that images are
represented in computers we represent
them in these in these matrices and we
have different color channels and it's
very much a one-to-one represent it you
know so one-to-one mapping between the
data augmentations we design I suppose
it wouldn't be possible to do anything
other than that unless we had some kind
of a latent representation or some other
layer of misdirection yeah I mean if I
were to you know preserve the semantic
information in images I would really
like to try simpler things like self
attention or visual attention in general
if I might so you know constrain my
model to put focus in specific semantics
or you know the region of interest in a
particular in a particular thing in any
given image so there might be some
synergies here as well I will when we do
the down meant with when we apply the
documentation policies like random drops
or things like that I mean crops in
general could we do not replicate those
things by incorporating things like self
attention or visual attention in general
in other words to allow our model to you
know understand the different semantics
of the region of interest in a
particular image why we already know
that self attention works pretty well
but yeah I would love to see some
ambition studies which is 6 2 data
augmentation policies specifically for
you know constraining our model to focus
more on the semantics of the images and
and I'll do that oh let me take us
through a couple of augmentations that I
think are really interesting that are so
this is one thing where they use these
things like neural radiance fields where
they can synthesize like like it
rotating the can to camp on this vehicle
this is it's like rotating the camera
around the car and this is this is a
different data augmentation you could
imagine yeah
so you see how they you know just
another example of it take this one
image and then can rotate it this would
be more of like as Tim was saying like
the the real kind of like a data
augmentation that reflects the real
nature of these objects it's possible to
predict a depth map and I know some of
the techniques for doing this free D
thing is they predict the depth map and
then they can they can turn it into a 3d
scene and then they can do some pixel
infilling and then effectively what
they're doing is they're augmenting
different camera angles which is
absolutely incredible yes you can
construct these like voxel scenes from
the dev mat right as you're describing
and yeah it's amazing it I mean it's
yeah it seems totally different than you
know random cropping the image my
intuition is that if we you were saying
it would be great if we could use
generative models to augment our
training data but it just seems to me
that that's not adding anything but once
you have a level of sophistication like
what we're talking about here imagine if
you could cut out the semantic
information and then do something
halfway between data augmentation and
data synthesis so we know it's a dog and
now we can permute lots of different
camera angles and colors and lighting
and so on imagine if we could build a
scene representation as a kind of sparse
factor graph not too dissimilar to what
Benji Oh is talking about you can see
that if you assert unless of fist
occation and how you capture semantic
information then you can combine it
almost infinitely it seems to me that we
could do some really cool stuff then
yeah yeah definitely it's like the
priors that create the data augmentation
might be these other models like the
depth estimation model is trained or pre
trained and transfer learned and then
dropped into this pipeline right and and
like the generative model it's like it's
like a whole separate model is getting
put into the framework the frame
the frameworks complexity kind of seems
to be expanding because like let's say
you want to do the state augmentation
you needed to train a depth estimation
model as well as the classifier so it's
yeah it's way more complex and then with
the generative model so like this we're
talking about semantic data augmentation
the the dog example like yeah we see
this is an elephant and now we can fill
it out in all these different ways I was
just gonna make the point that the GPT
three thing is really clever but it's
only happening in that initial domain
the surface domain it's incredible but
it's because it's memorizing effect
essentially it's it's such a huge model
whereas the kind of thing we were
talking about having that level of depth
and having lots of you know first of all
let's predict the depth map then let's
do some spatial augmentation then let's
do some semantic augmentation and I
guess what I'm kind of teasing towards
here is that at some point if you
capture enough clever augmentation rules
it starts to become indistinguishable
from magic
and this is the philosophical debate
about intelligence that if you capture
enough priors
then at some point you have
inadvertently created an intelligent
system or a system which is so
intelligent you no longer recognize that
it was just a whole series of priors
that you created right yeah and now the
priors Rob and I I guess I like it
better to have the prior come from like
a depth estimation network then to have
it come from me designing like rotation
and flipping right sounds more like AI
network well but why why not my ID
conception is that there would be a kind
of hierarchy of things that would happen
and maybe it's not too dissimilar to how
the human brain works and the irony is
in the 1980s we had these things called
expert systems and people back then
thought that if you could capture enough
knowledge in knowledge graphs and
databases and enough logical rules and
you know then you have intelligence and
in a weird way that's true because when
you have enough of these rules cat
then all of a sudden it becomes
indistinguishable from intelligence and
maybe that's what we need to do hmm
yeah it's kind of like brute forcing all
the data right like you brute force all
the different transformations the data
can make and then you memorize it in the
model it's like our talk on local to
broad generalization and this is yeah
like let's just memorize all the date
let's just build such a data so they can
memorize it and it's useful it's in the
middle isn't it because one one extreme
view is you can't share everything
explicitly and then the machine learning
view which I would I would call GPT
three a personification of that is it's
purely data-driven and you don't capture
anything and I think what we're going to
do is meet in the middle we're going to
encode a lot of information possibly
into some kind of taxonomy but these
rules will generalize just like on
alphago the way the planning works it
doesn't explore everything in the tree
it still uses the policy network so it's
kind of like a combination of an expert
system and machine learning and getting
that balance right at some point maybe
we'll just reach this magical milestone
where it just actually becomes
intelligent for all intents and purposes
so I mean to that end I still find the
the whole idea of you know domain
adaptation pretty questionable even with
the image GPD model by opening eyes so
there they had mentioned universal
feature representation for visual
features and stuff I still don't do not
really find that I mean how could we
learn visual representations that are
universal and food generalized to
different domains and also you know
would also align to different tasks has
been I mean the entire idea of domain
adaptation and things like task
adaptation was but touched upon in the
rethinking free training and
self-training paper so one possible
direction I would like to see is to you
know putting more efforts towards
learning universal feature
representations for you know but that
align will with different tasks and also
adapt adapt will to different domains
and the second thing what I would like
to see is to you know it's some kind of
joint training framework where given a
task I
would not only learn that a given task I
would also try to learn some kind of
data orientation policy if that's
required so yeah this is something I
would love to you know it's know myself
as well so yeah then there's two things
in it that I'd like to get at the first
being this idea of in domain like GPT
image GPT is trained on what like all
the image data and and then so you're
just going to sample from that
distribution to augment your data set
but probably a better approach would be
you know fine-tune it in domain and and
let the generative model at least start
to see the new domain right like don't
just take it from some like I'm very
skeptical on this idea of a universal
representation I think you're always
going to get a better result from
fine-tuning it in domain and then I you
know domains and then tasks that that's
another kind of thing to wrap your head
around right what I mean that so I think
you know this paper of had an exploiting
training they you know the the
generative model in this case is
training on some crazy amount of text
and but then they fine-tune it in on the
new data set the smaller data set to get
it more in domain with its generative
data augmentation so yeah I agree with
you I I am super skeptical on the idea
of a universal representation that isn't
gonna be better by fine-tuning in domain
at least with respect to domains I don't
know what I think about tasks you know
this idea that like you're training a
bunch of different tasks and that leads
to a better representation I'm not sure
but I think about that within the second
part of this inner outer loop
optimization where we're simultaneously
doing like an outer loop that learns
data augmentation and an inner loop that
trains the model what are your thoughts
on that how like to me it sounds like a
computational headache like it sounds
like you're gonna have to have this data
center of computers to do that so yeah
there will always be some kind of
trade-off with regards to you know
visual representation quality and at the
same time computation and stuff but the
way the firms like opening is
approaching the computation with regards
to pursuing research I
and there's something that I might see
in the future but yeah the computational
complexity is would be pretty damn high
if I were to you know train on this kind
of joint training framework with a quad
core like GF j 50 or even imagine it 21
K so the computational cost I can only
imagine but yeah yeah well make like I
like poet I don't know if you're
familiar with this idea of like
coevolution of agent and environment and
I think it might be more efficient than
outer loop inner loop gradients like
gradient through a gradient Mammal style
I think the coevolution thing I mean I
don't know this this kind of meta
learning where it's like out of the
inner loop I think it's tricky to wrap
your head around it and and you know I
because I've never really have any
hands-on practice with it because of the
computational requirements I think would
come from testing say poet where the
agent is the classifier and then the
environment is the subset of data its
trained on and then you're trying some
kind of you know yeah wait the point one
I still need to explore it but yeah I
mean because the point on computational
complexity with this kind of thing inner
and outer loop optimization it's it's
pretty married I would say listen Conor
and I are preparing a video on AI
generating algorithms at the moment
we're going to do a deep dive on Jeff :
and yeah so if any folks have you know
any kind of takes on that or want us to
cover anything in particular reach out
to us that yeah that's in the works at
the moment I don't know whether now's a
good time that it's like you're also
interested in machine learning
interpretability and explained ability
right yeah I mean that's one of the
domains that I am currently studying but
I don't consider myself to be a very
poor expert of this but yeah I'm
definitely interested in investigating
models in deeper ways so what are your
thoughts about that because and I work
in industry at the moment and
the way I articulate is machine learning
is just a new paradigm of software
there's no nothing hyperbolic about it
it's not really intelligent actually it
but it's it's it's a new type of
software in the sense that before we
used to explicitly instruct the computer
what to do and now we give it examples
of what we want to do and it produces
this black box piece of software and
it's the high interest credit card of
technical debt because we don't
understand what it does and you know it
probably doesn't even do what we intend
it to do it doesn't generalize to
previously unseen data and it's not
robust to adversarial examples and in
the life cycle of production we have all
of these different experts involved in
the process we've got these geeky data
scientists and then we've got these ops
people and you know we need to test it
for fairness and who does that and so on
so how does this sit with you because it
seems to be quite a complicated thing
you know the type of explain ability
method we use depends on whether it's a
structured model whether it's a vision
model and what I'm kind of thinking
about in industry as well it seems to be
relevant what the risk profile is so if
it's something which has an
anthropocentric objective then fairness
is super-important and if it's something
which could it's making consequential
decisions then we need to have a
reasonable level of understanding on its
behavior because we would that we would
only use machine learning and if it does
something better than software could do
that that's the whole reason we use
machine learning is it it works better
than writing lines of code to do the
same thing so so how do you wrestle with
with all of that yeah first thing first
I mean it's important to frame your
problem statement in the first place
without you know going to you know try
to engineer a machine learning pipeline
so you would want to ask questions like
you know whether a simple heuristic
algorithm could you know solve your
problem just the way you mentioned if I
mean with traditional rule-based or any
kind of software if it's possible to
solve then I shouldn't be you know using
using a hammer to kill iraq so and yeah
things like machine learning systems can
you know fail in all possible ways they
failure silently it's not gonna give you
any null pointer exceptions and so on so
being being a good and ethical machine
learning engineer or any umbrella term
that you would take it's important to
understand that your model is actually
working in the way it's supposed to be
working I mean things like incorporating
monotonicity constraint will you know
come up with simpler models where you do
you know the fix it on us on a
particular set of constants and you'd
either decrease it and increase it and
then you you know observe your models
predictions and you know see how the how
the prediction dynamics are getting
changed and stuff so it's not only just
important for your stakeholders but also
being a responsible machine learning
engineer should be should be something
that we should think about even more I
mean if you do not if you do not you
know understand your model the model
that you had developed in the past no
one else might be able to understand
sort of it right so yeah that's that's
where I see you know a great need of
being able to explain your models
it's alts it's not it's not only for
that stake holding purpose and so on
it's also incredibly helpful for
debugging your machine learning models
in the first place I mean take looks
like integrative gradients or grad cam
that allow you to you know see if your
model is focusing on the parts of your
image in the diesel in the expected way
so it's also incredibly helpful for
morally debugging as well so our W
during the inference time your model
might be making wrong predictions so
techniques like this would allow you to
you know explain your months and at the
same time would allow you to give up
your model well I hate to be like
bombarding everyone with data
augmentation but I you know I'm very
skips gone grad cam and things like the
open AI microscope that try to you know
take apart the directions these
gradients and stuff I think that's gonna
be really hard to figure out but this
kind of like input/output testing with
data augmentation this paper won the ACL
2020 best paper award
yeah like designing these negation tests
named entity recognition augmentation
vocabulary perturbations it's like data
augmentation to input-output test these
things is my guess for the solution to
interpret ability you knew I was going
to pick this up I was going on a logical
intellectual journey and I was going to
end up with Marco Rubio and you just
taken a shortcut yeah well we'll get to
there in a second now I I agree with him
so I interviewed Marco Rivera on my
channel last year and I think he's going
about this the right way but to come
back to what you're saying sorry you're
right this is not a box-ticking exercise
this is something that data scientists
need to be doing throughout their entire
process and then of course that it's a
multidisciplinary process and they'll
you know engineers and Ops people will
take onboard this but starting at the
very beginning a data scientist should
be debugging their models using these
methods just to just to establish if the
model is actually doing what we want it
to do because the the famous example
with lime I think is predicting a husky
or something or a snow snow leopard I
can't remember what it is and a lot of
vision models will just learn to predict
you know because there's snow there so
it's not even paying attention to the
Sun to the leopard it's looking at the
snow so the first thing you want to do
is establish does my model actually do
what I think it's doing and this whole
thing rabee Rio says that a model and
examined is not worth using you know and
I completely agree with that but then
there's the bigger piece about is my
model robust because models don't
generalize very well and especially in
vision we can't possibly train it on a
representative sample because there's a
combinatorial you know explosion of
possible examples going on but but yeah
that this does bring me on to what Conor
was saying which is that I think all of
these explained ability methods are only
interactive they need to be subjectively
interpreted by data scientists they
can't be used in an engineering pipeline
so then we should start testing because
the other thing is we don't necessarily
need to understand how a model works we
need to understand what it's doing we
don't understand how
an aeroplane pilot flies a plane right
what we do is is we test the airplane
pilot as much as possible and that's
what we should do with what Roberto
introduces which is this notion of data
grouping and counterfactual examples so
that's when you say does my model work
well for all demographics of interest so
it might be between men and women or
different racial groups for example and
can I come up with counterfactual
examples like for example semantically
equivalent adversarial examples to try
and flip the switch on the classifier so
if you think about it that there's a
whole kind of suite of different model
validation techniques we can use where
we are yeah that is well I think you
know simple monotonicity constants can
be really helpful you know they do not
they they are not only simple but they
are highly effective I would say and
they can be pretty much applied to any
kind of data I would argue not only just
for tabular data sets but monotonicity
constants can be equally be incorporated
in textual and visual models as well so
that's there and one thing that I wanted
to point out here is you know maybe
chasing chasing - developing models that
are implicit Lee are you explainable and
interpretable would be another good area
to pursue so incorporating things like
self attention in the model where you
would constrain your model to you know
put attention in the specific regions of
interest so that you know you can
instant instantly visualize the
attention maps and debug your model and
explain your model in the first place so
yeah that's my date I mean why you know
do why go for host training explain
ability methods when we can try to at
least come up with models that are
implicitly explainable and interesting
that that's really interesting I think
there's a continuum of explained ability
I know Microsoft have released a library
called interpret ml and that's
essentially it's a really really simple
way of doing machine learning so it's
taking the the strategy of simplifying
the machine learning model and once that
but then the question is when you have
these more sophisticated models like
transformers models it's it's very do
can constrain them like you said that's
an interesting approach but ultimately
these models have got possibly billions
of parameters in and we don't really
understand what they're doing we're not
even close to understanding what they're
doing and so the next question is if I
was building a risk management framework
for models in in financial services they
do use things like decision trees and
support vector machines even though that
they're strongly regulated and the
regulators have come in and they've said
okay well we sufficiently understand
what's going on here but it's really
subjective how do you assign a level of
interpretability on a machine learning
model does it depend on the algorithm
does it depend on the data does it
depend on the task how'd you start to do
that yeah I think I would first start
with the data because yeah they died the
better half of any machine learning
model
so once the regulator is or the you know
system balances kind of give me a true
assessment of how good my data data set
is then I would incorporate incorporate
the other things like you know my more
learning algorithms and so on so yeah
data would be the first factor that I
would put emphasis on maybe they just
entertain our readers why don't we ever
listeners why don't we quickly pivot
into this it's kind of neuro symbolic
idea that is a bit different and could
be interesting with explainable models
so here we have this data set called
Kleber where it's this good example of
the problems with deep learning right
now you ask it how many cubes do I need
to zoom in a little bit on the Cir you
ask you questions like how many cubes
that are behind the cylinder are large
so you have to think it to see this
cylinder you have to reason about being
behind the cylinder and then the size of
the object so this approach would be we
use the system one model which we you
know cannot interpret at all I think and
then you use it to fill out this table
of describing the objects it's detected
and then you use the another system one
thing with the language the question and
you put that into a symbolic program to
execute so it's like it's like an SQL
instruction where
you're gonna filter the data based on
the table that the vision model is
figured out so this kind of paradigm
where you have the the neural system or
the system one that fills at the table
and then parses the question and then
you have the symbolic execution of the
information this might be you know this
might lead to more explainable models
although you know I I'm kind of just
getting familiar with these kinds of
models myself and I think this system
right here this neural symbolic vqa I
think this is the like the later of it
you know I I think this is the prime
example of a system like this but either
you come across this kind of paradigm
and you know do you think this is an
interesting approach for deep learning
yeah I'm yet to actually read this paper
but yeah I think combining something
from system one and combining some
things from system two in a in a
systematic fashion like this would be
pretty helpful because yeah it generates
some kind of you know take some kind of
annotations that are that are not only
good for learning the downstream
representations but they are also highly
interpretable in the first place like as
you mentioned so I am definitely
interested in exploring more of this but
unfortunately I haven't get this this
looks absolutely fascinating I need to
read this the first thing that came to
my mind is what we need to do is
something like an autoencoder
but the latent representation is this
kind of abstract scene representation
that would be kind of cool right so then
I could generate a new scene from a
scene description so I can say I want to
have three large cubes and I want the
green one to be here and the red one to
be there that would be kind of cool can
you explain this question pausing thing
so and so we can say now that we've
generated this semantic rectangular
description of all of the things I can
now ask a question how many cubes are
behind the cylinder that a large okay
and it goes into an LS TM encoder so
what's happening here yeah so the LS TM
encoder is mapping from natural language
and it's like sequence to sequence right
it's like translating the question into
these programs I'm not sure exactly
it probably will give use command 1 and
then command 1 goes back into the
sequence and you know like how you shift
the sequence and the sequence the
sequence I set up I think is once we've
got this table of semantic information
then we can reason about it symbolically
so I think this lsdm encoder is just to
turn a natural language query into a
symbolic query yeah yeah but yeah that's
how interpreter 2 and then and then it's
more interpretive all right because we
can see exactly what it did and exactly
how it came to thinking about how many
cubes are behind the cylinder they're
large yeah it's really cool it reminds
me of a typical set search engine
because when you go and use Google of
course it's not just a full text index
it's also d structuring and enriching
your query so if you search for shopping
items for example it knows that oh this
is a shopping query and I want to find
trainers that are of size 10 and it's
actually turning a natural language
query into a kind of database query and
that's kind of what this is doing is
turning your natural language query into
a semantic query that can you know that
can reason about this table of results
that the encoder gave us right yeah like
a question answering system you like a
multi-hop reasoning thing you need to
take the question and then decompose it
to get the pieces I feel like I don't
know like what year did Wayne Gretzky
win the NHL championship or whatever you
need to first find out who Wayne Gretzky
is and then you need to find out not a
good example but you know you need to
decompose a question so yeah pretty
interesting cool ok so just just to
finish off pruning so we had Robert
Lanza last week what are your thoughts
on on pruning syak yeah I think pruning
is pretty much here to stay and we we
should be you know seeing more words on
pruning in general because pruning not
only allows us to approach new neural
networks and the boil optimization
landscaping
but pruning is highly effective for many
practical deployment related scenarios
right so yeah I'm pretty hopeful about
the current about the current phase in
which pruning is being developed I also
checked out the recent Super masking and
super position paper which is pretty
amazing they extended it to you know
continual learning and all all the stuff
but yeah I mean I was absolutely amazed
by the you know a by by the use of
something like that in in something like
kind of continual learning so yeah I'm
hopeful about pruning and I'm excited to
see what floating gives us in the coming
days yeah the continual anything is
quite interesting just in case for any
folks that haven't read the super
position a super Marcin super positions
paper it it's all about this concept
called lifelong learning and machine
learning and what that means is that you
can train a machine learning
architecture to do a particular task and
then if you continue to check to train
it on another task it very quickly
forgets the first task is called
catastrophic forgetting and it makes me
think a little bit of transfer learning
as well yet you have to be very very
careful when you transfer learning to a
convolutional base because you can very
easily destroy the underlying
representations and it makes you think
that there is a very kind of sensitive
network of pathways in a neural network
that if you know they can be disrupted
very easily and then they won't activate
anymore so yeah your your thoughts on
lifelong learning yeah I mean if if
there's a significant amount of
disconnect in the domains in the very
first plant then it it probably won't be
useful to you know transfer the weights
of the previous task to another probably
random initialization would work wonders
there but yeah I mean just to reiterate
on your point you know we need to be
extremely careful when we would transfer
weights from past one to pass to
specifically when there is a significant
amount of disconnect so yeah probably
you know having some kind of rewinding
thing when you are
during the weights from task 1 to pass
to might be helpful but yeah I'm
skeptical about that so with your
article on prune it's already started to
pivot it a bit but or maybe Tim do I
want to stay on this with one more thing
all right we'll stay on it just a tiny
bit more in there and then we'll move up
I mean I'm I suppose part of me is
thinking that this lifelong learning I
can't really think of that many use
cases for it it seems to be useful in as
in a in a predictive regime where you're
interested in task one now and then I'm
interested in task 2 and then I'm
interested in task 3 and then maybe I
want to come back to task 1 and I can't
really think of any situations when that
would happen because in reality what I
can do is I can just stratify my data so
that I always have some representation
of task 1 even when I'm training with
task 2 so it does make me think why do
we need to have this clever concept of
having you know the the masks for the
specific task so can you can you guys
think of an example I think I have a
good one with Gant training like the
discriminator needs to learn the
generators distribution and then the
generator changes it and it forgets the
original distribution so the generator
goes back to that one and then it's this
is the cycle but collapse is going back
to that first distribution which is crap
and producing crap but the discriminator
forgets and the gradients it's not
easier to go back to the crappy
generation that it is to progress
forward yeah but but I think to address
that particular problem today mystic
discriminators well proposed so I don't
think you know something like lifelong
learning well you would you know ideally
transfer things from task one to
different tasks would specifically apply
to you know mitigate this problem in
gans where after you know learning about
a particular distribution from your
generator you actually forget about the
to true distribution I think there were
some synergies in the relativistic
discriminative people so yeah that would
be less computationally expensive and
that would be a simpler approach to go
with so currently I was exploring this
enhance super-resolution gain mantra
which was actually coded by one of my
universe
he actually used a relativistic
discriminator and that indeed enhances
the kind of image generation in the very
first place so yeah and using
relativistic discriminators also helped
you know help in the knowledge
distillation in the you know in
producing the final overall enhanced
image in the first place from the
student network so using really
ballistic discriminant was one of
between t and medians they're both for
the enhanced enhanced image generation
and also being able to you know they
still that knowledge into a lesser
complex to the model so the relativistic
discriminators where you look at like a
patch of it right is that the yeah i
think it well i think they are a bit of
a separate i think the idea behind
catastrophic forgetting in ganz I think
even a seventy by seventy window is
going to forget as the gen as the
distribution changes so so the main
question that's that's really domestic
discriminant is trying to addresses okay
so the generator would try to produce an
image which which would be you know
classified as true by the discriminator
but what realistic discriminate that is
trying to do here is it would also try
to you know reduce the trueness of your
true distribution at the same thing that
way generator would get challenged mode
so that's there right right is
interesting
so pivoting back to the topic of pruning
so on your article where you show how to
implement pruning does it with that
implementation do you actually get any
benefit from it because you know you're
adding complexity by multiplying it with
this mask right or how I like how are
the current software tools for actually
using pruning and you know getting gains
from it yeah so I did not I actually
give gift some pseudo code who you know
implement a very basic version of
pruning but I did not actually trained
it I the one that I trained in the
article that you see was
was trained using the pruning API is
offered by the tensor flow model
optimization toolkit so I did some you
know comparisons sometimes some
execution time comparisons but I did not
see any massive or significant time
increase when I incorporated the pruning
API state so basically when you are
using the pruning ApS from tencel flow
model optimization tool kit you will
also supply some kind of pruning
schedule to it which did not really add
to any kind of complexity at least with
regards to the execution time of your
model but does it so do the current
tools take at least a memory down a lot
so you could say fit a larger model in
the GPU that you have yeah so this is
something that I would need to discover
because I train my models on fashion a
minister in this so yeah I would need to
scale it up to be able to lament of that
but yeah so as far as per the
documentation and as per my
conversations with the developers of the
of the pruning API they did not really
mention about significant computational
time increase when you would use the API
because I think we're seeing you know I
think it's kind of like a software
engineering effort that needs to happen
now for us to realize the gains of
lottery tickets and pruning and I
pitched this when they're talking to
Robert this idea of we need to build
some library for using the lottery
tickets where we're all using this
library called like lottery ticket
finder and what it does is it does a per
layer thing and you do gradient
checkpointing so you can put a much
bigger model in your GPU that you could
otherwise manage and then it's gonna do
this these things of rewinding and
linear remote connectivity to prune it
like earlier on so we're not trading
this big bottle for a hundred bucks and
then if it crashes
we need the we need the software tool to
send the report back and say here look
at this data we just got this model
crash the linear mode connectivity thing
didn't work the rewinding thing didn't
work and I think that's how we're going
to get to a better understanding of this
kind of
phenomenon with the lottery tickets is
that we need to start using it good we
have the ampere I'm sorry yeah yeah just
like it it's like one last thing is that
the Nvidia ampere a 100 architecture is
now like these are gonna be faster too
now that the new hardware is gonna
handle sparsity better so it's not is
still it's just a memory thing right
like you're not gonna you know with most
GPUs I think it you're actually gonna
make it slower by multiplying this mask
by it right and that's oh but this new a
100 thing is starting to see speed gains
too but most I think memory is a huge
problem of my GPU has 3 gigabytes of
memory at home and it's super annoying I
hadn't really thought about this much
but I assume that once you have this
you've learned this binary mask and you
have this sparse representation of the
neural network can you not write some
code just to copy it all over into a
condensed version so it's no longer
sparse but the memory footprint is
lowered presumably you can do that right
does it need to I guess what I'm saying
is because it was originally a bigger
network do you need to maintain that
footprint and keep it sparse
or could you now kind of compress it
down now that you know we don't need
most of the weights yeah yeah what oh
yes I've seen this it's like compressed
sparse row I think is what they call
that yeah yeah why would you need it ok
can't you make a sparse network into a
dense matrix multiplication I also I
can't find anything that are there well
I mean again this isn't something I've
done but it might be challenging because
every single layer there are just a huge
number of parameters and you may be it's
not possible to compress it down because
all of these different because you know
you you have an adjacency matrix
essentially and they need to be able to
address each other so is it actually
possible to compress it down or not
this is where we need this is when we
need Yannick well you're thinking about
that I've got another little train of
thought that I want to hit syak with we
were speaking I mean just for people
that don't know about the lottery ticket
hypothesis that the idea is this
wonderful Jonathan Frankel guy came up
with this iterative magnitude pruning
algorithm so you start to train a neural
network and it's a reasonable intuition
that the weights that have a magnitude
that near to zero you can just prune
them and you can do this iteratively and
you can prune almost other day let's say
90% of the weights and the performance
especially for simple architectures
actually outstrips the original
architecture but the the magic thing is
that you can train it from scratch and
it's normally not possible to train your
networks from scratch if they are that
sparse you need to have all of these
parameters to train them now what we end
up with is this sub Network this lottery
ticket and with Robert last week we were
talking of ways to draw intuition on
what's happening here now Yannick use
this intuition that these sub networks
resonate with the optimization algorithm
they provide guardrails and they let you
go to the to the optimum really easily
and Robert had this this intuition from
Yan laocoon about the more dimensions
you have them all kind of do you know
the more directions there are for the
optimizer to go in to find the local
optima I mean seiyya howdy how do you
kind of conceptualize this process in
your mind I think I still go with what
Yannick approach in the way Yannick
approaches it I mean so the lottery
ticket would contain the set of
parameters where your optimization
algorithm would react to in a better way
than the other ones so yeah yeah the
optimization algorithm would simply
resonate with that set of parameters in
the for Sophia I concur with what
Yannick approaches okay then
it begs the question we've learned this
this subnetwork this lottery ticket and
a lot of papers show that these these
these lottery tickets they generalize
better now philosophically they
generalize better for that task would
they generalize better cuz you know
before we were talking about Universal
representations do they generalize
better in general or is it just for that
task I would argue that they would only
generalize for that particular task
although I haven't really you know seen
fine-tuning fine-tuning a through
Network for other you know for for other
downstream tasks in the very first place
so yeah this also you know gives us a
pretty important question to explore
yeah it seems to invoke this thought
that's do we want to learn you know
shalay talks about generalization being
really important and you could make the
argument that this is this is not
generalization this is actually learning
something very specific that works very
well for this particular task
so I've with these larger architectures
you know when we do transfer learning
kind of what's going on there is is you
have all of these lower level features
that are starting to light up and
activate for a new task with a lottery
ticket it seems like we're removing all
of those mechanics where we are just
selecting the thing that works really
well in this situation or maybe no no as
so we are building the kind of we are
building the notion of significance for
the particular task only I mean with
respect to your task these parameters
were not that significant so when you
would try to do transfer learning here
so we would need to take the same notion
of significance with your previous task
with which the importance of the
parameters was selected in the first
place so that's that's why I guess the
paper on movement pruning was proposed
where they considered the movement of
the gradients as the criteria to you
know to do the
pruning when you when you do the fine
tuning to downstream tasks in the first
place
so yeah I would love to see you know
more works in this regard so how do you
you know formalize the notion of
significance for pruning the parameters
in the first place and how would they
generalize well when you do you know
transfer learning for downstream tasks
so but the paper and movement tuning
does give us a pretty good starting
point but yeah I'd love to see more
words on that yeah but I figured yeah
and it's super interesting this idea
that we could have one lottery ticket
and like say ResNet 50 and that works
for imagenet see for 10 Street View
House members or whatever the image
thing you're trying to do but then they
then it comes back to the software
engineering like PR people like using it
because once you get the actual
optimizations in place then people will
start using it and then more research
and understanding will come out of it so
to me that's the problem is let's you
know build the software to do the
lottery tickets and all that yeah I mean
if you try out the pruning API is from
the tens of your model optimization tool
they do offer a lot of different things
at least compared to the other
software's that are available so my plan
next week is to actually you know see
how how quickly I could you know
implement the vanilla lottery ticket
hypothesis using the pruning API from
tens of your model optimal she'll take
it so if I I'm able to do it I'll be
sure to let you guys know yeah
definitely send me the article yeah
because it's got to the point now where
some of these state-of-the-art models
have I mean I think there's one
announced with a trillion parameters and
these are things which even that you
know the Microsoft's of this world can't
use in production it's it's an it's
incredible so we need to have ways of
meaningfully reducing these models but I
would imagine training in the larger
space and then reducing we'd still be
much better off yeah maybe I'm reaching
here to but I think even with our
knowledge distillation you might have an
ensemble of teacher models and
those models could be useful if you're
gonna if you're gonna label a bunch of
data and do knowledge distillation there
could be a rule there too I mean I'm I'm
kind of reaching with that one and I
haven't read anything that like
compresses the teacher model before
doing knowledge distillation but maybe
it's useful maybe if you didn't like an
ensemble of teachers or something or you
know really high capacity or something
like that because like with the in
Facebook post is this thing where they
use 3.5 billion images from Instagram to
do knowledge distillation and
self-training and well that scale you
know quantization and compression is
you're doing 3.5 billion inferences
that's a lot like at some scale I guess
it could fit in there back to that and I
would also like to see the algorithm of
seen flow getting more used it allows us
us to you know prune the network's
without having to you know access any
data in the first place so yeah I'd love
to see how thin flow is playing out in
the real world yeah and philosophically
I'm really interested in what are the
trade-offs because you could take you
know like Bert is a denoising
auto-encoder so you could you could have
a Bert model which was pre trained on
Wikipedia or some large corpus and then
it's fine-tuned to do question answering
and you could then kind of distill that
down but what's the cost for that
because it was trained on something else
is it is it getting better at question
answering because you know they put the
perennial problem in machine learning is
overfitting so is it is it just
overfitting to this particular thing and
is it actually losing out on the general
generalization power that it did have I
guess we've lost sight of overfitting
right like gbg3 and sim clear be -
they're both defy our intuition of
overfitting and that's kind of the point
of both of them right some clear V -
they're like yeah you train it more like
bigger models are more label efficient
it's like when the paper on big transfer
they also suggest to use big models big
training schedules and stuff yeah
maybe we don't use the language of
overfitting we use the language of
generalization and is there is there a
cost to increasing the specificity and
distilling the model down I don't know
it might be outside my music it might be
like that a double descent interpolation
threshold thing where we're so far past
it that we've like left the atmosphere
of overfitting I think you'll be tricky
don't really understand it I mean yet to
actually fully dive into it so they
would thought what food for thought
certainly is well it's been an
incredible journey
sonic thank you so much for joining us
it's been an absolute honor debut one we
really appreciate it
it's my own hands amazing course a week
we will see you folks back next week ok
now that's fine we can we can stop the
recording that is a